[Applause]
welcoming Dwayne to the Hall of Fame is
the answer Allen Iverson
Dwayne Wayne
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
thank you
um
he Nation y'all in here
[Applause]
um
I don't got much time
coach pop took all the time let me
[Applause]
let me get to it
I first I want to start by acknowledging
all the individuals
um
and the amazing women from 1976 Olympic
basketball team
on going into the Hall
Tony
Powell Dirk
we were all linked together already
but being on this journey together
getting to know one another
as men and not as competitors
it's been hella dope
for dark and me has been therapy
[Applause]
who would have thought that we would be
on the same team after all of our
battles
but here we are
and it's one of the greatest teams I've
ever been on so thank you guys
I want to thank
Harold L Richards High School in Oakland
Illinois
I want to thank Marquette University in
Milwaukee Wisconsin
I want to thank
the Miami Heat
in Wade County
[Music]
I want to thank the hoop Hall
here's my final love letter
the first memory I have of holding a
basketball
was when I was five years old
and it wasn't love at first sight
but one thing I knew for sure
was there's something inside of me would
come alive
every time I had that ball in my hands
I've got to credit my dad
for my love of the game
he's what you would call an everyday
Hooper
and there was a court in Chicago
chances are my pops took my brothers and
me
so we can play against grown ass men
to gain their respect
and there was a basket and a run there
we were pulling up to the lakefront
Foster Park Blue Island rec center and
any local gyms and Parks anywhere in
Chicago
the best thing about that time was what
the game taught me
I had a chance to see the way to get I
had a chance to see the way basketball
connected people
just about hanging out with my dad my
uncles and his friends
my love of competition came from seeing
them go at it
it wasn't about anything other than
their pride and the Love of the Game
if you've been around basketball long
enough you know you know how raw it gets
they had loud arguments about bad calls
you couldn't even think about calling a
foul if there wasn't some blood involved
you had to play through it all
the trash talking in those games it
probably wasn't appropriate for kids to
be around
but that's the game I grew up on
that's the game that raised me
after all those games my battles really
watching them sit down grab a cold beer
laugh and joke about any and everything
about work family
and definitely who got buckets dropped
on the head that day
you know as a kid all you need is an
opening
but I live for back then was any
intermission in the game
it could be a long time out
a long argument
water break
somebody getting pissed and throwing the
ball over the fence
a break between games
and that was a chance for me to run on
the court and grab that ball
and imitate my dad
I took it
thing is though at five
the ball was always too heavy to get to
the rim
or too big in my hands
but little did I know
that this object
was going to be the vessel that changed
my life and my families
by the time I was nine years old
I didn't have to look far for elite
level basketball
my hometown team the Chicago Bulls were
the greatest force on Earth
I look back on some I look back on those
days at some of the best of my life
all my brothers Demetrius Donnie and I
did was eat sleep talk think and dream
basketball
it was my obsession
the game gave me eaglepar's excitement
and frustration
see I was clumsy as hell back then my
hands were too big for my body and my
feet was growing just as fast
before and after school before and after
my games I studied the player who had
replaced my pops as my favorite Michael
Jordan
he captured my imagination and filled my
aspirations all at the same time
I bet if you give me enough time I could
find that Come Fly with Me VHS that I
watched before every game I played
the way he soared through the air felt
like forever
he created moves that made me
immediately rush to my backyard to
recreate them
game two of the 1991 NBA Finals the
Bulls versus the Lakers my dad's
favorite player Magic Johnson
Cliff leviston drove Baseline
threw it to MJ who was waiting at the
free throw line
he took one dribble
he took off with one hand like he
normally does
and then he decided to switch it in
mid-air to the left
I bet you can hear Marv Albert in your
head right now
a spectacular move by Michael Jordan
after seeing that I couldn't tell you
how many days and nights were spent
practicing that move I wouldn't stop
practicing it until I mastered it
I was hoping to bring some of his style
into my own game
by 17 basketball was my soul's love
language
to help give me an identity
it was a safe space that allowed me to
be expressive and passionate
I realized that basketball was my blank
canvas
I used it to reimagine my life
no matter what was going on in my life
it was my sanctuary
it's my way out
I needed to reimagine life
not just for myself
but for everyone I loved
the game is why I discovered who I could
become
it showed me that on the other side of
hard work was a success I craved
it taught me the value of resilience in
the face of adversity
how to bounce back stronger at their
defeat
through the game I discover who shows up
for me when I win
and when I lose
my confidence was found through the game
it helped me find my worth
far beyond the courts
you see I've never been a stranger to
adversity
I'm speaking of being labeled
academically andeligible as a freshman
in Marquette
at 19 finding out I'll be a father for
my sophomore season
That season my 10th game against Wake
Forest I taught a meniscus in my left
knee and at the end of the season
I had surgery to remove my meniscus
there was also 2007 when I had to have
two surgeries at the same time
one to repair my Toro labrum and my
dislocated rotator cuff in my left
shoulder and the other on my left knee
again
and finally in 2012 right after our
Championship parade down Biscayne
Boulevard
I had to have my third surgery on my
left knee
eat surgery each rehab it pushed me past
lemons I didn't know I had
I could have given up
I wanted to
I never second guessed myself a third
fourth fifth guess myself
but I never allowed my injuries to
Define me
I'm on the stage because my beliefs have
always been stronger than anyone's doubt
so to all the hoopers I hope you take
this to Heart
no it's never about your setbacks
it's how you respond
the blows you take are fuel
the limitations people put on you are
actually inspiration
no one who comes from a community
community that I have has ever left a
legacy worth remembering by having it
easy
as I reflect on my own destiny and the
impact that My Heroes Have Had on my
life
I'm reminded
that our heroes are not always perfect
instead they possess a relatability that
makes them touchable and real
when anyone speaks about Allen Iverson
that's exactly what they say
he's real
so AI
I need you to know this
I watched you
with all
because I saw a reflection of myself in
you
the way you played the game was exciting
and fearless
it didn't matter who they put in front
of you they wasn't going to stop you
I know I tried
it didn't matter what they said about
you because they couldn't measure the
size of your heart
your authenticity Unapologetic attitude
resonated with me
your Swagger Unique Style for rocking
do-rags braids the baggy shorts it's an
untucked jerseys the earrings the chains
the throwback jerseys
all combined to create an image that
broke the mold
you challenge conventional norms and
became the poster child for
individuality and self-expression
inspiring countless individuals who
Embrace their own uniqueness
you brought hope to those who grew up
with limited resources
you showed us that success and greatness
were attainable even in the face of
adversity
your struggles made your accomplishments
that much more remarkable
AI you are a living breathe a reminder
that Redemption and growth are possible
you inspired a generation my damn self
included to believe that coming from
nothing was not a limitation
but motivation
I wore an arm sleeve throughout my
career because AI did
I respectfully order number three
throughout my college and NBA career to
represent the love and the respect that
I have for this man
so from the bottom of my heart
you are the culture and we love you and
we thank you Allen Iverson
thank you
to make it here the Hall of Fame you
never do it by yourself
I've had incredible mentors play pivotal
roles their wisdom guidance and loyalty
are as much a part of my story as
anything else
they helped me discover parts of myself
I never knew existed
you not only taught me the X's and O's
of the game
but you also imparted invaluable life
lessons that have shaped the very
character of the man that I am
your beliefs are my potential your
guidance through adversity and your
unwavering support have made all the
difference not just in my game but in my
life
I would have never evolved into the
player that I I would have never evolved
into the player that would have played
that could have played with the Mount
Rushmore of talent like Shaq and LeBron
without y'all teaching me about the
importance of we versus me
dead mentality made it possible to
understand when sacrifice was needed for
my teams to win
so thank you Jack Fitzgerald
Larry Butler
Coach K Tom cream Stan Van Gundy Pat
Riley and Eric spoaster
I love you guys
[Applause]
throughout my career
there have been many Milestones like the
triple double versus Kentucky to advance
to the final four in 2003.
we didn't get the chip there yet salute
to my brother Mello
but my Marquette brothers and I left a
permanent mark on our University
he caught his basketball forever
from there I was able to reach five NBA
Finals with the Miami Heat
and win three
I could talk about my accomplishments
and the work I put in Forever
but that didn't happen without my peers
coaches and honestly you
the fans
your cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
your cheers and booze
[Music]
are part of my life soundtrack
you may come to work every night the
best job in the world
I was blessed to play with
and win championships with some of the
best to ever dribble basketball
teammates who understood how to play the
game on and off the court
overcoming challenges together
celebrating victories together and
creating memories together
is what stays with me
each victory was a testament to
resilience and determination
each loss a reminder of how precious
winning actually was
being named the All-Star 13 times in my
16-year career all NBA on both the
offensive and defensive ends I never
wanted to cheat the game
and in return the game gave me a
lifetime of amazing memories
with all that being said nothing
compares to the bonds I've made along
the way
I'm thankful for Travis Diener Robert
Jackson
the real right Quinton Richardson Quran
Butler Lamar Odom Eddie Jones Alonzo
Morning
[Music]
Gary Payton
Antoine Walker
my bad little brother Mario Chalmers
[Applause]
and Ray Allen to name a few
I also play with people who protected me
and gave me a bigger sense of purpose
Shaq
Chris
LeBron and UD
[Music]
[Applause]
they changed the way I would be viewed
in this game forever
with Shaq
I learned how to be Robin to his Batman
and then become Batman
watching Chris Simply Be himself
while giving us all to the game
but not cheating his family out of their
time
gave me a friend I could look up to
spend it four years with LeBron in Miami
I watched him not take one single day
off of being great
and my brother UD and I we learned how
to be selfless leaders
together but the protection he provided
me on and off the court
[Applause]
provided the safety of a big brother
and it allowed me to bloom and Blossom
so I thank you I love you
[Applause]
off the court
Another Blessing in my life
is Henry Thomas
been on the stage tonight it simply
wouldn't be possible without him
my job title he was my agent
but in my heart he was far more than
that
if you're really blessed in life you get
to meet angels on Earth
it was not a day that goes by that I
don't hear him saying you got this my
man
I know he's looking down at me right now
chewing his tongue
with a proud dad grin on his face
Hank we miss you
we love you my man
to my loved ones
the ones who have become my lifeline
y'all are my Safe Haven
a place where I can always Retreat to
with minimum fear of judgment
I'll laugh with you
I've cried with you
I've been saged by you
I'm protected by you and I'm loved by
you
I am who I am because of all of you
you're the embodiment of unconditional
love
and that's all I ever wanted and needed
that's all I ever wanted to show in
return
so I want to take this opportunity to
recognize a few of my loved ones and
when I call your name because we've been
here all day I want you all to stand up
so everyone can see your faces
Carmelo Anthony
if y'all can wait till I finish the
names before y'all clap uh it'll be all
day
Chris Paul
[Applause]
Chantelle Cohen you may be at the top
somewhere I love you there you go
Andre King
Richard Ingram
Bob mattelis
Lisa mattelis
Tracy Union
trigill Wade Johnson
Davion Morris
kavya James
is I your way
thank you all for being there for me
and for loving me in the most perfect
way possible
I appreciate you guys and I love y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
just sit down now
my wife gab would you please stand
thank you for making our house a home
thank you for making sure our kids feel
seen
heard and protected when I'm not around
thank you for learning every ref's name
in the NBA
and for screaming at them so I didn't
have to saved a lot of fine money
I know I'm I know I'm traveling for work
this year during my anniversary
so I want to say thank you for being on
this journey for me
with me these past 15 years
thank you for learning to love my
imperfections
just as much as we've enjoyed and loved
the moments of perfection I love you
mom
mom would you please stand
your strength to overcome your own
personal adversity
it's something I've always admired about
you
to have a mother who loved me enough
to know when it was time to allow my dad
to step in and Lead the Way
is one of the most unselfish acts I've
ever witnessed
thank you for seeing me and I'm making
my life about you
it allowed me to Blossom in an
environment that kept me focused and
dreaming
thank you for showing me that our lives
don't always go as planned
but with the right amount of love and
support
our lives do go exactly as planned I
love you
thank you
pops
would you please stand
[Applause]
I started this off thanking you
and I want to end it the same way
I owe you a debt of gratitude that I'll
never be able to repay
when I would cry and say I can't
you made me go harder
you push me the limits
that I didn't know were inside of me
the hard work I put in was because I
didn't want to let you down
those countless hours in the backyard we
would compete against each other like
strangers
and built me to last
those days that turned into late nights
of me working on my left hand
so it was just as good as my right
it made me an Unstoppable Force
that time you got kicked out of the game
as my coach
and snuck back in the side door
and coached me from the stands
just to get kicked out again
it showed me that there was no
limitations on how you would show up for
me
it's the exact same way I try to show up
for my kids
so even though I hated being called
little Dwayne
I admired you as a kid
I admire you now
we had the same exact dream
and we carry same exact name
Dwayne Tyrone Wade
to know we Hustle hauled away to the
Basketball Hall of Fame is God's will
so pops
I know your knees a little sore
but will you join me on stage
as we take our rightful step
into basketball heaven
[Applause]
this one right here
this one is for my father
I love you and I'm thankful for you
I love you too man
we're in the Hall of Fame dog
[Applause]
[Music]